all right how about
now
I don't know what you're talking about
Miss Wicked Wolf hey everybody I hope
everyone's doing okay and if you're
not if things are really
tough then I hope that they get better
for you soon
homebody I can't make you any promises
about what will or won't happen but I
can send you my hopes for you for things
to be brighter in the near
future yes happy trans Awareness Week to
all hope you're all doing well if you
aren't aware I am trans I don't talk
about that a lot I kind of keep it on
the down low so um you know you may not
have been aware now you can be just for
this week though I won't make you aware
any other
time
ah it's Simon don't know if you remember
me under the tag Freddy Mercury uh I
mean probably but also I have ADHD brain
and memory
so there's there's there's a lot that I
tend to not remember or
recall thank you I think I need that
message today I hope that uh anyone who
needed it will hear it if not from me
than from
somebody it has it has been a little
while because last time when it normally
would have happened was
Halloween and believe it or not I had
stuff to do on Halloween
so um yeah I I was not going to uh be
keeping it uh on its normal schedule um
so a quick reminder for people uh I will
try and keep keep up with the chat as
best I can uh what guarantees that I
will get to your question or comment is
to do it as a super chat which will also
get you a little heart of appreciation
from
me was really obessed with the rocky or
picture show if you don't remember I
totally get it I think I kind of do
again I'm like keeping on top of the
chat I'm hydrating and so like off the
top of my head like I think so but like
also specifics fade from my mind
quickly Paul manan's birthday 64 you
would not know to look at the
man was I murdering people what you mean
on
Halloween when it's for a ritual it's
called sacrifice you got to get the
terminologies
right H been catching up on the MCU this
past month I'm down to just a
105 and a half hours H I'm not sure how
much of the MCU is currently
worth catching up
on um Loki is worth catching up on
second season of Loki was good which I I
needed that I I I really
did
um what do you think about the
renumbering of Doctor Who on Disney plus
Oh you mean that we're starting with
season one
again I don't love it but I also get it
like as a branding exercise I get it we
got to figure out what the hell we're
going to call the now closed off era of
Doctor Who that we were calling new who
or modern era Doctor Who we got to
figure out what we were going to call
that now that that's done and we're
starting a new thing and we need to
figure out what we're going to call the
new thing because we can't just keep
calling this new who the other thing was
new who I don't know somebody else
figured that
out do I think the actors will vote Yes
on the deal yeah I do I would be shocked
if they didn't I'll have a video out on
that hopefully
tomorrow doesn't murder just kills it on
the
regular there we go finally got to watch
the eth doctor movie it was glorious
it's fun it's a bit of a mess but it is
fun and Manan is is really
good sacrifice what does this Council
really do here um it I can send you a
copy of the charter um you do have to
put in a formal request in
triplicate um but once I get that in I
can start the paperwork to get you a
copy of the council Charter um that will
not have everything laid out in it but
we'll give you the references of where
you need to go to get everything so that
you can understand everything that goes
on
here why aren't they putting all season
of Doctor Who on Disney plus because Mac
still holds the streaming rights on uh
on the what what was previously called
the modern era
I'm so I have a video kind of catching
up on dror who that'll be out on
Saturday um but like I'm I'm slightly
surprised that it appears that Max had
the streaming rights
separate um between when they were
getting the brand new stuff and how long
they were keeping that era of Doctor Who
the streaming rights I would have
thought those would have been the same
day and date but apparently they're not
um or if Disney um like bought them out
for the new stuff they didn't also buy
out for however long is left on the
contract for Max to keep streaming the
previous era
so yeah that's just kind of How It's
panned out any interest in the Mean
Girls movie musical
no no absolutely not I did note did
watch the trailer they seem to be trying
to hide the fact that it's a musical
which is never a good
sign when are we going to get new
new
newo well it will be premiering in new
new New
York uh with the cat
nurses I've ever played the game the war
game mouse trap yeah in grade
school uh first stream well welcome
Corwin nice to have you
here there should be three stages of Hud
original reboot and current reboot yeah
you're right geek Fielder reboot would
not actually be accurate because it was
a
continuation I don't know it's like we
can't force what people are going to
call it it's going to shake out
eventually did I see the Echo trailer I
did uh
uh it it it was a
trailer yep sure
was B we have such a separation between
drama and music in the west sad really
I'll tell you this it it can be funny
sometimes when I went and saw
um
uh Sweeney Todd in the movie theater
they had also downplayed it being a
musical in the trailers for that like
they downplayed it a lot I knew it was a
musical um because I'm a theater nerd
but I went and saw
it and the film
starts and the first character I think
it's Anthony started singing and I just
heard this guy like one road down like
10 seats over just go what the
hell he had no idea
and I feel kind of bad for him but I got
to kick out of
that I need to watch do who but I have
no motivation to watch 13 seasons of the
modern era CU it's not technically
modern anymore well the thing is like
it's all still the same continuity so
it's not like it suddenly doesn't
count
but um if you are not already familiar
with Doctor Who it does sound like the
new stuff I I would say probably
starting with shuy goa's stuff not
necessarily the specials with tenant I
think those would probably be more
continuity tied but it it really does
sound like they're trying to have a a
new entry point um which even if they
weren't
renumbering probably was a good
idea because they've done that a few
times like obviously series one with
eckleson was a new entry point Series 2
wasn't too far off um Series 5 with um
11th Hour that was a new entry point um
woman who fell to Earth was designed as
a new entry point like it's it's not a
bad idea to to refresh like as a general
thing
uh I just listen to
listened I listened Miss money
Penny I just listened to a fourth doctor
audio named fever Island which features
a character who believes himself to be a
James Bond character Tom Baker gets to
play blow Feld
interesting AR the trailer for the new
Garfield movie I did
too i' forgotten that Chris Pratt was
voicing
Garfield and then I heard him I was like
all
right hey and I'm not going to say he
ruins it cuz as someone who liked
Garfield growing up and still watches
some of the old specials and still has
love for Nostalgia for them even if it
sounded exactly like Lorenzo music boy
would I still not
care Supreme Omega coming in with the
first Super Chat of the evening thank
you kindly hope you are well on ET
unlike other Blockbusters like Star Wars
or Jurassic Park it's interesting ET
never had a sequel a remake spin-off or
expand in uh into a franchise I find it
oddly
special I wonder how much of that was
how badly the video game Tanked
like I I I wouldn't be shocked if like
the notion of merchandising ET if that
idea was kind of canned after that
tanked so badly now obviously it's not
et's fault that game was just terrible
objectively but you know going by
corporate logic where you just look at
the numbers um I wouldn't be shocked if
that was a big uh
impact and I think part of it is while I
think holds a a special place for people
who were young when it came out or close
to when it came out um I think it's not
something that is really kind of passed
on
generationally the way Star Wars or
Jurassic Park has like I don't even know
if my kid knows what ET is my kid knows
what Star Wars is my kid knows what
Jurassic Park is they don't care about
either of them but they know what they
are I don't know if my kid even knows
what ET is it it hasn't like it's it's
sat it's sat in the memories for those
of us who were there but it hasn't
really been passed on the way a lot of
the more
merchandise uh repeatedly merchandised
and squiz stuff did so I'm not sure what
the chicken and egg on that is I don't
know if maybe because it wasn't
merchandise as part of white hasn't been
passed along but I'm not sure if that's
the case but I suppose one can make an
argument I've heard a few people trans
people mind joke about dead naming
companies I.E still calling X Twitter
still calling uh Max HBO Max Etc is this
an acceptable joke in your mind yes
because corporations aren't people and
it's not dead dead names it's corporate
rebranding if you want to joke about it
as a dead name sure go ahead it is
Twitter by the way it's not X it was a
signed Twitter at Birth like I think it
is acceptable for Trans people to make
these jokes should cisgender people be
making dead name jokes even if it is not
about a
person maybe not but like broadly
speaking is an acceptable joke yes it is
they're corporations screw them they're
not people you don't need to Grant a
corporation the humanity that I expect
you to Grant to a person I expect you to
not d deadname a person because you are
stripping them of their Humanity
corporations have no Humanity dead name
the hell out of
them
please
[Music]
ah let's see I miss Lorenzo music he was
Lorenzo music had a great voice have I
seen the men the man who fell to Earth
actually I still have not ever seen that
one I love David Tenant I might just
watch his Seasons not going to lie well
you'd be like many
others do I think Johnny deppon made a
good Sweeney Todd yeah I he wasn't a
definitive Sweeney Todd by any means but
no I thought it was a thought it was a
solid uh portrayal of the
character there are ET Comics that
expand on the lore Joe star formerly of
screen junkies was obsessed with the
story see like that's part of the other
at least to me although granted I'm not
a lore person in general so this is my
opinion nine comes out of 10 regardless
but like the lore of ET who
cares
obviously some people do but like from
my
position the like the nature of the
species he comes from what other species
they encounter out out there you know
why were they visiting earth like none
of that matters to the story that is ET
which is about the bonding of of ET and
Elliott it's about that connection the
the
lore doesn't
matter like it matter to some people and
power to them I hope they get enjoyment
out of it I don't get it I don't get it
I'm just I'm not a lore person in
general lur is one of those things that
I
uh I kind of like knowing that it exists
but I super don't care like I like
knowing you know before it all started
getting before it got bought by Disney
and all getting explain like I liked
that there was deep lore for Star Wars
cuz like knowing that it was out there
kind of gave depth to things I've never
cared about what that lore actually was
though like I've never
cared a British series of ads for
British Telecom that start ET well
naturally because you have to phone
home movies you uh on movies you saw
under age 10 you're holding back on
sharing with your kid even if the films
were branded for families no at this
point anything that I saw at the age of
10 or younger that I haven't shown my
kid is because I know my kid has no
interest like I I made a video about
this years ago but my my
child's interests are not my interests
my interests are not their interests so
you know I love Star Wars I love Doctor
Who I love Star Trek I I love all this
stuff and they could not care less like
we find stuff that we both like
but I I am I am not one of those Geeks
Who uh was able to indoctrinate my child
into my
Geeks um I gave it a shot in so far as
like I tried to see if they had any
interest in watching Star Wars when they
were like four five they got like five
minutes in and didn't care so I'm like
cool we'll move
on Joel the dreamer hello there Joel
thank you very much for the Super Chat
in the anti-woke movement there are a
lot of people without any conservative
politics that are that there just
made okay hold on let me try this again
in the anti-woke movement there are a
lot of people without any conservative
politics who are there just made Western
games are Les
sexualized other than that they might
even be leftists how to engage with them
okay so you're talking about people
who are broadly speaking probably not
overly politically engaged but have been
okay so actually this oh
boy this is a whole thing
so the radicalization of Gamers
especially was uh heavily co-opted by
the right and it was done on purpose and
it happened in the wake of gamergate
gamergate regardless of what some people
thought it was or what the narrative
that they tried to form was was started
as a harassment campaign that was its
purpose that was why it began they
managed to Shield it as a consumer
Revolt but it it never was even though
there were some people involved in it
who did believe that that was it was
that's what it was that was never what
it started out was the point was
harassment from the
get-go Breitbart News latched onto
gamergate and wrote it to massive
success because they recognized that a
whole bunch of young angry men and that
is not what all gamers are but that was
the gamer as a
demographic was young white men that
they were angry at the sense of their
space being invaded by Outsiders which
is a narrative that doveet Tails very
easily into harshly right-wing
conservative ideologies because if you
can you take somebody who's going you
know women and feminists and gender
specials and all this are invading my
gaming space and if they are holding
that as a belief it's not going to be
that hard to convince them that Mexicans
and Muslims and uh people who who want
to put you in jail for getting the
pronouns wrong are invading your country
unfortunately the anger is what the
right is able to grab on to and that's a
big part of why it's easy for them to
fall in with the right and why it's hard
to get them out because the right
validates their anger whereas the left
by and large is going to be going here's
why you need to ease off and why your
anger needs to take a back seat or you
need to con reconsider it and try and
not be so angry it doesn't validate
their anger because while their anger
may come from a misunderstanding of the
world and a very sheltered view of the
world because you know women minorities
trans people Etc have been in gaming
spaces from the freaking beginning but
they they felt like they didn't have to
deal with that before and now they did
and when there's an anger that comes
from that the side that will validate
their anger and tell them you are right
to be angry now I'm going to give you
other stuff to be angry about is so much
easier to fall into them the side that
says okay you you really shouldn't be
this angry though
so how do you how do you
redirect I think
probably the most effective way is to
redirect the anger which is still a
dangerous thing to do because anger
while anger can be very productive anger
by its nature can be very destructive I
think this is honestly where um the work
of someone like Stephanie Sterling is
very helpful because while unfortunately
she did she has dealt with a mass Exodus
of her subscribers since coming out as
trans the truth is um part of the reason
that happened was because she was
getting that group before they realized
she was trans and a chunk of them
rejected her he was she was getting them
to redirect their anger not at um you
know sjws and woke people but at the
corporations who were ruining games so
whereas the right was taking their Ander
anger and going your right to be angry
you should be angry at these
minorities um people like Stephanie
Sterling again prior to coming out which
had its own you know baggage that came
with it and caused its own separate
problems not problems like it's a bad
thing like it's great she came out she
should have but like caused a problem in
terms of her metrics um but like she was
able to take that anger and go you are
right to be angry at these corporations
who are stuffing these games full of
predatory monetization and destroying
video game developers and firing the
people who make the games that you love
so I
think if you're trying to redirect if
you can't get them to back off of anger
probably the best bet is to try and
shift that anger towards the
corporations that are actually making
video games worse like
demonstrably that became a whole
thing can we all agree the new Beetle
song sucks haven't listened to it don't
care
have I heard of lwis the Jack
jackan he is not a Jacko Lantern his
name is Lewis yes I am
aware um but independently of each
other my my boyfriend and my child both
made me aware of
that um I forced myself to watch all
three Star Wars movie even though I
didn't like them just so I could get
nerd
jokes that's
commitment I mean I guess I kind of get
it if if you if you are
are um moving in nerd circles is just
such a standard point of reference that
yeah I guess I could get
that honestly I can't wait till woken
anti woker no longer terms in our
discourse I'm sick of it I'm sick of it
too but the thing is Mr L the terms are
new but the conversation is not before
wok and anti-woke it was sjws and
anti-sjws before that it was political
correctness and anti-political
correctness it's the same crap it gets
rebranded intermittently listen to the
latest prisoner podcast nice voice need
to get a record deal oh yeah no my uh
that that that cold that that was that
that wasn't that wasn't nice that that
took a that took a toll on my throat
just finished streaming the original
TMNT weird hearing the turtles refer to
each other by their full names they did
do that a bit more in the original
didn't
they let's
see or blame Canada we
don't blame Canada do I have your
Christmas decorations up
yet what month is it
do I have Christmas decorations up it's
November it is the front half of
November no no I
don't that was a slightly exaggerated uh
reaction but no absolutely not have I
seen the movie Little Monsters I have
long time ago it's
that movie's a
thing I'm aware Miss Wicked
Wolf
uh it is not Christmas month
[Music]
Molly
Christmas starts on the 1 of November no
it
doesn't Christmas is allowed to
start on Thanksgiving day after the
Macy's Thanksgiving Day Parade the end
of it when Santa shows up at that point
it is allowed to be the Christmas
season
while work I uh accidentally told
someone Merry Christmas it was all a BL
all if I was still in an office job and
somebody told me Merry Christmas on
November 1st they better be able to
[Laughter]
run
H I was listening to the Trans Siberian
version of Carol of the Bells I love
that I immensely thought of you because
I know you did that your high school
talent show oh wow I feel like like
you're building a dossier on me Miss
Wicked Wolf you make me nervous
sometimes uh have I taken down the
Halloween
decorations I think so I didn't put that
much up this year it was mainly just the
pumpkin
um to be fair it's not like Thanksgiving
as we know it is great
so
in my mind there's two aspects of
Thanksgiving one of which I think is a
good thing and one of which one of which
is not there is the familial traditions
of Thanksgiving which I hold dear and
for
me are completely
divorced
from the other aspect of it which I'll
get to in a second in much the same way
that for me Christmas is a secular
holiday I've never celebrated Christmas
as a religious observance and along the
same reasons I've never celebrated
Thanksgiving as a uh as any kind of
Praise of the
pilgrims um and reminder I'm allowed to
say what I'm about to say because not
only did I have relatives come over on
the Mayflower I had three of those
people those are my people that's my
family I'm allowed to say what I want
[__] the pilgrims and [__] The Narrative
of Thanksgiving Thanksgiving as a coming
together joining together a being
together and being thankful for each
other for your time for your um family
for your loves for having someone there
in hard times that is all wonderful the
[__] narrative in the background of
it scrap it get rid of it I'm here I'm
here for the turkey and the pie I don't
need any of the autal get rid of it
because it's all a
lie
I Rowan I I don't think Jonathan Glazer
and I are are ever quite gonna see eye
to eye I don't really have any interest
in his movies here's something I read
that was funny
uh Grandpa in my days kids were seen and
not heard grandson yeah so were
movies
uh Halloween should just be October 31st
s at all no Halloween is all of October
you let the witches be
witchy I mean the witches are going to
be witchy the rest of the year too but
like let them be more open with
it Thanksgiving also gave us the movie
Free Birds okay never saw
it when you learn eus is older than the
existence of Christian well yeah because
it's a co-opted holiday same as Easter
so
I I need to check the Discord reminder
that the Council of Geeks Discord is a
patreon exclusive perk I'm going to pop
over there to see what questions have
been asked and inquired and I will get
these as through as quickly as I can
feel free to um drop anything in the
super chats if you like because when I
get back I'm probably not going to
scroll back through the chat to catch up
so any of these thoughts you have that'd
be the best way to ensure that I see
them but let me get through the Discord
real quick I'm going to a Comic-Con this
weekend what are some must bring items
for
you water bottle um that's a big like
for me I'm a bad person ask if you're
looking for recommendations on what you
should bring for me it's water bottle
um uh art portfolio and business cards
uh I need to bring my business card so
that I can write off the uh the con as a
business expense
um and when I say portfolio I have this
thing to like put any commissioned art
that I have and I have that in my
shoulder bag and water bring water don't
buy the water there it's going to be
overpriced and the bottle is going to be
this big and you'll down it in one gulp
I'm using Comic Con photos to mark my
transition on te is there anything that
I do to document the process not really
I didn't like I've got a couple of picks
of like earlier development point with
my chest and a couple later but like I I
never like formalized like oo I I'll
I'll take this picture in this pose that
at this point this point this point this
point like I didn't I just didn't really
do that um I've just and like part of it
was I didn't take a lot of pictures of
myself before I had the body that I now
have
um because I didn't feel that good about
it how am I I'm pretty good I am pretty
good I just want to say I hope that
coyote versus Acme movie gets sold to
someone that will give it a home because
I really want to see if it spawns a
sequel coyote versus Warner
Brothers um I it will be if it does I'm
waiting for the dominoes to finish fing
on that once they do I might have a
video out on that because it's been
interesting to watch it play out but I
kind of need it to hit its end point
before I'm going to say anything or
before I decide if I'm going to say
anything um remember I said I'm watching
uh Torchwood
reactions I was watching the one for out
of time there's a bit where Gwen is
explaining modern sexual Norms to a girl
from 1953 and her responses so I like if
I like a boy from 1953 and he wants to
sleep with me I should let him would be
your response to
that
uh I don't know I don't think I can get
my heads space into that fictional
situation well enough to give an
answer yeah I don't know do you think
that it's a problem that some people
conflate character growth with
Redemption I've also been watching
reactions uh to a show that ends the
first season having a character who was
sent to Earth as a sleeper agent almost
beating the sun to death he had he had
to maintain his cover a final moment of
him being like I can't do it then
leaving the planet I've seen a bunch of
reactions like oh he's a good guy now
because he didn't kill his son I think a
lot of fandoms have a tendency to
oversimplify the journey of redemption
or to assume that all character growth
is Redemptive um I think for a good
counter example you can look at
something like Breaking Bad Walter White
has a lot of character development and
it's not positive because he is a
monster but it's easier to keep an
audience invested in someone who at
least has the possibility of getting
better than someone who's just going to
get worse and worse and worse I I do
think fandoms are often um overly quick
to
forgive um at the first sign of like oh
like they'll take the first sign of a
character heading in the right direction
as like oh Redemption like no that is
literally step one on a path I mean
that's part of why I I continue to
praise um she on the princess princesses
of power so much I genuinely thought
they could not redeem Catra but the
reason they did and the reason it worked
is they spent the majority of season 5
doing it they didn't just have her turn
sides and then be like everyone has to
forgive her now like no we're going to
make a point she did horrible stuff she
has bad personal habits she is going to
backslide she needs time to get better
she needs support to get better not
everyone's going to be on board and like
that's the kind of thing that most of
these things don't do it's not that far
removed from the video I did a year or
two ago talking about my problems of
redemption through death it's a similar
core Pro core premise with part of my
problem of that which is the idea of one
good thing being used to denote a camera
a character now being redeemed no no if
you have spent a long time doing
horrible stuff no you are not redeemed
with one
action when I was a teenager one of my
autistic special interests was the late
Roman Empire that's actually why I have
this
username I'm sorry I'm laughing because
that's a meme at the moment uh thinking
about the Roman Empire one time I was at
my grandfather's house the same time as
my cousin who was 6 years old I started
telling him about a documentary I saw a
claiming archaeologist might have found
the tomb of St Nicholas he started
crying and I was really confused for
several seconds oh crap I just told him
Santa's dead oh
no oh
no my mother and Aunt just told him I
was lying as a parent how you have
handled
it my go-to probably would have been
um that it was a different s Nicholas
that it's not that there was more than
one that probably would have been my
panick goto as opposed to um accusing a
te a teenager who didn't lie of lying um
but yeah
that I'm sure it was a messy
moment am I more excited for Sandman
season 2 or good omen season 3 good omen
season 3 because Sandman season 2 like I
know what it's going to be I will be
interested in seeing it for the same
reason I was interested in seeing the
first one to see what has changed and
then made really smart adaptational
choices last time and I expect they will
this time as well but good Omens 3 is
going to be much more like I don't know
what they're going to do and I want to
find out do you can you think of any
superhero TV shows or movies that made
you like a comic book character you had
previously
[Music]
hated
no uh uh no I'm drawing a blank on
that I mean probably at some point I'm
coming up empty
though given that you aren't a fan of
Christmas specials in general how do you
feel if Doctor Who started doing
Halloween specials instead of Christmas
ones well if they were done with the
same feel of the Christmas ones then it
wouldn't make a difference what I don't
love about the specials isn't because
they're Christmas it's because they are
they have a a feel and a tone and an
atmosphere that isn't what I come to
Doctor Who for they lean into the camp
they're a bit pantomime and like I get
why and part of that is because of an
association with Christmas but if they
just moved it to Halloween and treated
Halloween in the same pantoy kind of way
I wouldn't I would not feel any better
so I've got a oh I've got to figure out
once the new ones are out I got to do a
ranking of all the specials which I've
never done
before Oh I'm going to piss so many
people off all right I am now back in
the uh in the main
chat let's see Captain
Lunar thank you very much for the Super
Chat what is your favorite sci-fi
concept m is robots artificial humans in
general since it blends with my favorite
monster I.E Frankenstein's monster
um
huh let me think on that like I don't
know if I have a defin like I I
I love the Blends I love the mix I love
I love the feel of the Star Wars Cantina
scene extrapolated out just weirdness
and Oddity and um things that feel like
they shouldn't exist in the same space
all just together I mean it's a similar
reason why I like fantasy it's kind of
why I tend to like science fantasy a
little more than science fiction most of
the
time uh did I watch many horror movies
in October I watched a few can't
remember now though I know I saw
some um are you aware of the penny
trading scandal going on at YouTube at
the moment
no no I am
not I'm now afraid to find
out geek version how often a day do you
think about the cling on
[Music]
Empire they're Penny trading your
m
all
right all right you got
me there's a possibility we'll see the
new title sequence as part of the mini
episode drop on Friday okay I forgot
there was a mini episode
happening uh Star Wars version how often
do you think about the Jedi
[Laughter]
Order
ah so Basta what uh what Willow polus uh
got me with is it's it's a
um it's a pun
because if you say penny trading alog
together and you add it with they're
Penny trading your
mom it's sounds like penetrating so it
was a set he basically up dogged
me
he pulled an up
dog
H can only choose one Sam the eagle or
Grover
right
ah
I why are why are we naming dror strange
and Multiverse of manness although
abbreviating is Doctor Strange in the
mom which you know had its
own thing will I be reviewing the tenant
specialist oh yeah oh yeah was all even
with the strike going on it was going to
be able to because reviews were Exempted
from the um request that
um YouTuber style creators not do
promote not do anything that could be
considered prom emotional
um reviews were were always separate
from
that excuse
me I don't really know what the how
often do you think about the Roman
Empire meme is about but I personally
think about the late Roman Republic a
lot more than the Roman Empire I I only
kind of get the
meme uh Michael
like I've seen it and like I've gotten
the feel of it but like I don't I also
feel like I don't totally get it was
there a time before Elmo get
out was there a time before
HMO
freaking jenzy kids get off my
lawn did I hear Sesame Street's doing
story arcs now I don't think I heard it
like as a thing but I think I kind of
knew
that yeah but because even when I was a
even when I thought I was a CIS man I
didn't really think about the Roman
Empire
Rowan wonder if a doctor who Marvel
crossover could happen maybe in the land
of fiction please don't
please
don't I never want to see another
crossover again so long as I
live I am burnt out on interconnected
universes and it's sour man crossovers
in general I just want things to be what
they are I don't I don't no I don't I
don't want any more crossovers of
anything they're not fun anymore they're
not fun for me to think about anymore
I'm I'm done I'm done no
more with Mel blanks Looney tun
characters I could tell it was him but
as Barney Rubble I had absolutely no
idea uh only do cross overs when it's
funny no just stop just stop we don't
need it we never needed it but it used
to the fun of a crossover used to be wow
can you believe this is actually
happening they're so freaking standard
now because of corporate consolidation
and a half dozen companies owning
goddamn everything it's not special
anymore and crossovers are never High
Artistic Endeavors the best one ever was
HR Roger Rabbit and the cross cross over
aspect of that is a background feature
cuz the primary story are characters
unique to that narrative so even in that
the crossover aspect is backgrounded but
the main thing that makes crossovers fun
ever at any point is that they're
special and feel like they shouldn't be
happening they're not special anymore
they're exhausting they're done
stop
please
how did I know you were Jen z k because
You' mentioned you're in your
20s Captain Lunar thank you for the
Super Chat in in the 70s we also had a
doctor who Fantastic 4 crossover but
fell we almost had a doctor who
Fantastic 4 crossover but it fell
through so it got worked into a
um into a doctor XP meeting Luke CJ and
iron oh I heard about that I've seen
I've seen panels from
that
uh you can never make Roger Rabbit today
because copyright law is even dumber now
well like the only reason it happened in
the first place was because Steph
Spielberg was producing he basically
became the goet between Disney and
Warner
Brothers Council of Geeks how they never
adapt DC versus Marvel but like what's
the plot of DC versus Marvel what what
are the major story moments where what's
what's the heartfelt emotional heart of
that story it doesn't have one because
it's just
spectacle and back when when crossovers
were special that was fine and that was
enough
that is not a time in which we currently
live would I take up yoga sure if you
paid
me Ram was so powerful my iPad fell over
you're
welcome I'm honestly shocked
that balky never met URL seeing as
family matters uh with was a perfect
stranger
[Music]
spin-off sitcom Universe
crossovers
ah didn't the doctor meet peard yeah
there was a there was a Star Trek and
Doctor Who crossover there was also a
Star Trek and X-Men crossover that was a
novel though I
think uh the plot is Superman meet
spider Spider-Man except they'd already
done that Bruce they actually did that
as its own thing before they did DC
versus Marvel as like bigger
things
yeah Captain Lunar I may be in the
minority here okay I am but I still love
Multiverse stories and the Multiverse as
a concept I love seeing how it's played
with I like a Multiverse story that
actually does something that could only
be done as a Multiverse that actually
takes full advantage of the concept I
like Loki both season I love everything
everywhere all at once I can still enjoy
Multiverse Stories the problem is most
things that have gone Multiverse have
done nothing interesting with them
nothing unique to them they've just
brought in alternate versions of this
character that character or the other
and you could have done that
anyway
it's
Marvel Superheroes get to learn about DC
heroes and go damn that's crazy and
weird and vice versa so much untapped
story
potential is it
though is it
really I don't think it
is Have You Ever Seen The doct Who par
skip with Rowan ainson I have John and I
have the controversial opinion of it not
being that funny which is something that
the uh especially the uh Doctor Who fans
who live in the UK uh like to hold my
feet to the fire over that I I that's
one of the things that they beat me over
the head as being a stupid American who
does not get the intricacies
of uh British humor like falling in a
pit over and over and over again for
some reason that is too sophisticated
for me I don't know man like it's
fine it all feels like real loow hanging
fruit jokes across the board
I don't think it's that good I it's I'm
not offended by it it's
harmless I just I don't get
uh I don't get I don't get why some
people are like think it's the the
funniest thing ever I just I don't I
don't get
it
ah you don't get us
man
uh me being the stupid American who
likes the TV movie oh yeah you're in
trouble now have I heard about the Red
Dwarf prequel series that's been
officially announced it was a prequel
that was said just before the events of
the pilot show oh yeah I'd forgotten I'd
heard about that I hope it doesn't
happen that's a terrible idea that's an
awful idea why would you do that
no
ah be just didn't think it was
[Music]
abfab course I got to put my glasses
back on immediately so I can actually
read the chat Supreme
Omega back again it's weird that
nowadays Marvel is the lighter
familyfriendly brand while DC is seen as
the dark one didn't it used to be the
other way around
um yeah
but not really okay
so
okay let me see if I can explain
this yes Marvel used to be considered
the comparatively darker one back when
it first started getting big because
Marvel characters were dealing with much
more real world problems like not being
able to to get a job not paying their
bills drug addiction uh amongst their
friends and and um real world bigotries
there were a lot more realworld problems
in Marvel and that lent itself to
comparatively darker storytelling to
what DC had traditionally done with you
know there's a there's an evil starfish
from outer space that we have to stop
which even in its darker moments was
light-hearted and silly enough that
didn't feel dark now I'm still hesitant
to use those terms because what we now
conceive of as darker Comics is Way
Beyond the ways in which Marvel was a
little darker than DC cuz it was a
little because it was more grounded in
real life problems and real life
situations and real life trauma that
came up more and then DC started
catching up with that but
[Music]
then but then
well then a couple of things happened uh
over a period of
decades um Watchmen and The Dark Knight
Returns came out and both of which are
thoughtful and interesting and have
things to say but are also dark and
then people went oh what makes things
successful is they're dark and then in
the 9s things got dark in the most silly
superficial way possible '90s dark is
actually kind of
hilarious um and and and kind of
harmless they just they just give
somebody a gun the size of their head
and all these banders full of bullets
going and it's so ridiculous you can't
even say it's dark it's too silly but
then I actually
think the thing that that really like
you you could say that the the trend
towards Darkness at DC was started by
Watchmen and The Dark Knight Returns but
I think the point at which everything
went to
hell was identity
crisis I think identity
crisis is not only a bad
story and a gross
story I think it did more damage to DC
and how the creators over there have
approached those characters in those
stories than any other single
story it was
gross it was
callous and it was wildly
successful and it has almost nothing to
say it thinks it has something to say it
barely has anything to say nothing that
hadn't been said 20 years before by
Watchmen by The Dark Knight Returns by
Miracle Man and an animal man and other
things
much smarter and less mean-spirited and
less cruel and less gross than that is I
I lay a lot of blame on the feet of
identity crisis that I believe that is a
deeply abhorent Story made worse by its
lasting impact the shadow of what that
story was and how that story felt and
how that treated its characters has hung
over DC ever since and yes Bruce Simmons
that is the one with Sue
dney uh identity crisis mine flame blade
was
a event in DC in the early 2000s that
started out as a lock door mystery and
devolved
into borderline
nihilistic levels
of darkness and it tainted the character
in the world in a way that I don't think
has ever washed off since even after one
full reboot and multiple soft
reboots definitely agree on identity
crisis how the writer thought it was a
love letter to those characters I'll
never know reading that introduction
where he claimed it was a love
letter made me physically
ill
like I never liked identity crisis there
are some things that that like I liked
at the time that I read them and I've
realized more of the problems like I
mentioned already The Dark Knight
Returns is largely and largely the
positive but like there's a lot of
problems with that book um or um The
Killing Joke there's some good stuff
there but there's a lot of problems too
and I recognize the more as time goes on
I never liked identity
crisis But as time goes on and I see
it's it's
stain just not ever getting washed off
of
DC I really deeply load that
story I really do I don't like it in of
itself and it's it it
just
GH it's it's gross it's a gross
story for no
reason that's the thing somebody
mentioned Sue dney that's the kickoff
that's not really what it's about and
the main thing that ends up being the
grossest thing in the freaking story and
it's really
gross has nothing to do with that plot
it's one 100% Superfluous has no impact
it's a red herring it's a dead end
there's no reason for it to be there I'm
talking about the Dr Light stuff if you
kind of know the story and if you don't
know the story I'm not going to explain
it I don't have the spoons
tonight but it's so gross and it's so
needless and
has nothing to do with how it started
and then the resolution of the actual
mystery plot is not only bad as a
mystery because it breaks fundamental
rules of mystery
storytelling but is also steeped in
Gross tropes and Trends and um
archetypes it's all gross that story is
gross as that's the that's the only word
I have to describe identity crisis is
freaking
gross the core idea of The Killing Joke
has been reused in Dumb better and
subsequent stories one could argue
potentially yeah
yeah do I use gen Z's slang if I do I
wouldn't know I
don't I I don't go out of my way to use
slang in general because I just assume
it's going to sound weird coming out of
my mouth whatever generation it's
from I suppose I could try and do older
slang on my hepcats it's cool
Daddyo nope no that no NOP don't like
that don't like
that can you do the Joker's line when he
has henchmen enter the art gallery but
in Mark Hamill's Joker
voice see he doesn't say that much
because they kick into the music right
away but so we're talking about the 89
Joker but the door gets opened after
everyone's been gassed except Vicky
Vil
Gentlemen let's broaden our
minds and then they immediately kick
into the uh the Prince song
and then then he's sitting down with
with Vicki so like he doesn't have he
doesn't say that much at the front end
he he stops
uh Bob from destroying one painting
because it shows a a mad person on
it no I kind of like this one Bob leave
it all right there we go that there
there's your fun
I sound like a boomer using gen Z slang
and I'm gen
Z what do you want my face on the $1
bill you must be joking do I look like
I'm
joking all right we're GNA wrap it up it
is 8
o'clock um but thank you so much for
joining me I hope that you all have a
lovely trans Awareness Week were you
aware that I'm trans
I couldn't keep it
going but uh in any case thank you very
much for joining me
um I will be on Twitch tomorrow um 10:30
a.m. eastern time um I'll be playing I
believe uh steam world dig 2 is what
I've settled on uh that I'm going to
play tomorrow uh and hopefully tomorrow
I will have a video out on the SAG Afra
um agreement that was cleared um and is
waiting for uh to be voted on by the
members Saturday will be a kind of a
catch-up video for me on Doctor Who for
all the stuff that I have not been
talking about and I think that's what's
coming up in the immediate so hope you
all take care of yourselves and please
remember that you are beautiful you are
valid and you are
loved you're the council I'm just
running the meetings and until next time
this Council Council we're back at the
council table money Penny this council
is a
Jour
m